The US faces a serious shortage of
primary care doctors — the very doctors
who provide critical services for poor
and elderly patients. By 2030, there will be
about 50,000 fewer primary care
physicians than we will need.
And those physicians increasingly practice far
from rural areas where people who lack
access to care the most tend to live. But
a new paper from AEI provides a solution:
Peter Buerhaus shows that nurse
practitioners can do much of what
primary care doctors do, and at a
fraction of the cost. The workforce of
nurse practitioners is growing, too,
especially in under-served areas.
And nurse practitioners are more likely to
treat low-income patients and people with disabilities.
So what's stopping
nurse practitioners from stepping up?
28 states restrict their scope of practice,
out of a concern for quality of care.
well, good news: Buerhaus shows
that such concerns are unfounded.
States should let nurse practitioners
do their job — disadvantaged Americans
need their help, and the rest of us
need a health care system that is affordable.
What do you think about Peter
Buerhaus' research? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.